[Music]
hey Justin you ask really need question
about Elon Musk you know there have been
wonderful things that he's been talking
about colonizing Mars obviously putting
a Tesla in space which is playing David
Bowie which I love he's a really
wonderful person and an inspiration to a
lot of us and one of the misconceptions
that a lot of people have is that
federal space programs like NASA and
commercial space programs like SpaceX
run by Elon Musk are in some type of a
competition and you know I am a fan of
all things space and one of the things
that has been so fun for me in the last
few years is the collaboration between
those two different realms of space
travel so you know for example NASA
routinely buys SpaceX Rockets to put our
payloads and our satellites up into
space and that means that as a NASA
scientist I've gotten to go to several
launches and landings of these Falcon
rockets and that's amazing
you know used to be that you would go to
a launch and a big rocket would go off
and everybody would cheer and then you
get in your cars and you drive home and
it was all done
the amazing thing now is seven minutes
later everybody just walks to the other
side of the building and watches the
first stage of that rocket land and that
is something that is mind-blowing your
eyes basically it does not compute you
cannot believe what you were seeing
because this giant thing comes down from
space faster than you could imagine and
this is something that's I know several
story high building it's a big thing it
comes careening down and just before it
gets to the ground
it stops settles down and then gently
lands and one of the things that I love
is that you don't even hear the sonic
boom until after you see it land you
watch this thing come careening down
then stop land gently and then you hear
boom boom because it broke the speed of
sound coming in and that is something
that I am just really amazed I live to
be able to see I love SpaceX and I love
NASA's collaboration I think what a lot
of people don't realize is that NASA is
one of SpaceX's major customers we
actually buy the Rockets and we've even
paid for some of the development of the
Rockets as well so it was never a
question of one or the other it was a it
was the ideas that we're collaborating
the more companies going into space hey
the better for us
lower the cost of the rockets and the
more efficient an industry we have and
hopefully the more people that think
space travel and space exploration are
good things then there are the questions
about whether Elon is going to build a
giant rocket that can take hundreds of
people to Mars and then this is
something that as a scientist you know I
am naturally a skeptical person that's
how I was trained
right now what I see is a really cool
idea
you know reminds me of a lot of my
favorite science fiction stories but
it's basically just that an idea I think
there's a long way to go before we
actually see any significant
colonization you know any significant
number of people going to Mars first we
need to get one single person to Mars
you know or a small team of people and
that is something that has proven very
very difficult it's not so much a
question that we can't build rockets to
take us there because even today you
know we have rockets that might have the
capability of doing that the problem is
how you would keep a crew of people
alive for the journey to Mars and then
also a life on the surface and get them
back that would be very expensive and
because the astronauts would not be
protected from the radiation of space
right now we really don't know how to
keep them alive it's not impossible
there's a lot of work that can be done
but when I see people thinking that
SpaceX is almost ready to send people to
Mars that's where I have a bit of a wait
and see attitude I would love to see
people on Mars I would love to see
SpaceX take people to Mars
I think the Tesla up there heading out
toward the asteroid belt is so cool
but there's a long way to go and it's
not easy I think we're not going to get
there from a single company or a single
nation even I think that for something
as large as a mission to Mars we need to
collaborate on a global scale you know
work with the Europeans work with other
emerging space markets maybe work with
several different companies not just one
it's not a single entity it's a planet
going out and exploring something as big
as colonizing Mars I mean that that's an
amazing civilization scale activity I am
somewhat skeptical that in my lifetime I
will see people walking on Mars
I hope we do I'm not holding my breath
[Music]
you